what's up YouTube it's been a couple
minutes since I've made a video but I
thought I would check in with you and
express a little gratitude because this
week the podcast eclipse
30 million downloads 30 million
downloads I'm just blown away I'm so
thankful and grateful to all of you out
there who have taken time out of your
busy lives to give me your most precious
asset which is your attention I really
truly honestly can't imagine what my
life would be like without the podcasts
that have this unbelievable experience
of sitting down with some of the most
compelling thought leaders and minds all
over the world and the fact that the
program is enjoyed by so many people
across the planet just warms my heart it
means everything to me so thank you for
that I think it's important to honor
these kinds of benchmarks to pause to
take a moment to really reflect back so
I'm gonna do that and kind of recap this
journey that I've been on in hopes that
my experience might be of some benefit
to all of you creators and makers out
there because it has not been that easy
of a journey it has not been linear for
sure twenty years ago I was drunk I was
an alcoholic and the only future that I
had was jails institutions and
ultimately death but by 31 I was able to
get sober and I started to begin the
process of repairing all the wreckage
that I had created as a result of my
drinking and using it took ten years but
I was successful in that regard by the
time I was 39 years old I was a
successful attorney I met my wife we
were building a family we built a really
nice home I had a really fancy car in
the driveway but on the inside I was
dying I was depressed unenthusiastic
about my life and I'd put on 50 pounds I
was basically a junk food addict on a
crash course with chronic lifestyle
illness and then I had a health scare
shortly before my 40th birthday and it
was one of those moments in time where I
realized not only that I needed to
change how I was living but that I act
they wanted to that I have the
willingness to make some really
significant lifestyle changes I adopted
a plant-based diet
I started getting fit again I went on
and conquered all these crazy ultra
endurance races and then about six years
ago I wrote a book about it it's called
finding ultra I came out in the May in
May of 2012 and it can't chronicles this
wild journey that I've been on and in
the wake of that book I started to think
about what was next for me what's the
next chapter what am I gonna do now I
wrote this book but where am I going to
invest my creative energy and I thought
maybe I'll start a podcast I had fallen
in love with podcasts during all of my
training for these crazy ultraman races
and doing epic five because I was
spending so much time on my bike hours
and hours and hours on my bike or
running on trails and I realized that I
couldn't just listen to music that whole
time and I started listening to podcasts
and this was back in 2007-2008
I took a look at what was going on in
the health sector on iTunes and
podcasting and I realized that there
wasn't that much great content there
were a few great shows but there wasn't
a lot of depth and I thought hmm maybe
there's something that I can contribute
to this and so in the fall of 2012
I got a microphone I turned it on and I
just started talking I had no agenda I
had no idea whether there would be an
episode - I didn't know whether I would
be any good at it
and I certainly didn't have any kind of
grand design or goal that the show would
morph and mature into the large entity
that it is today and just for context I
think it's important to understand that
in 2012 it was not cool to have a
podcast I certainly wasn't an early
adopter podcasting had been around since
I don't know something like 2006 but in
2012 there wasn't the level of
mainstream interest that we're seeing
today but I didn't care
it wasn't an effort to growth hack my
audience it wasn't some kind of land
grab and I certainly didn't look at it
as a
to make money it was just something that
I love doing it was an authentic
expression of my creative voice and so
over the last five years
without fail I have uploaded a new
episode every Monday today I have 347
episodes I believe and I've never missed
a single week consistency has been king
in growing the show to the point where
it reaches as many people as it does
today so for those of you out there that
have a spark of inspiration you have
this impulse to create something maybe
you want to write a book you want to
start a YouTube channel you want to run
your first 5k whatever it is the lesson
that I want to leave you with today the
insight that I want to provide you with
is that you don't have to have it all
figured out at the beginning the
important thing is that you just begin
so if you have that spark if you are
inspired to do something don't fall
victim to analysis paralysis you don't
have to have all the answers you don't
need to know where it's going to lead
you but you do need to do one thing and
that is begin the second thing I would
say is release yourself from that
pressure to be perfect
it's not going to be perfect in fact
your first stabs at anything are gonna
be probably not so good or bad I can't
even go back and listen to the first 50
or so episodes of the podcast that I did
because I cringe I'm so much of a better
interviewer now then I was back then but
that is beside the point the point is
you have to get over that self-imposed
sense of having to do it great the first
time out because you're gonna fail so
embrace that failure failure is part of
the process of growth and maturity just
focus on what you love and don't be
afraid to fail in fact well commit fail
often the other thing is it's fine and
cool and awesome to be inspired by other
people out in the world if you want to
start a YouTube channel follow the
people that inspire you that are doing
amazing things and allow their insight
and their
example to inform your path but
ultimately at the end of the day you
have to find your own voice because it
is your unique perspective that is the
ultimate differentiator it is the one
thing that nobody else has and so invest
in yourself and determine what that
voice is and devote yourself to bringing
that specific unique beautiful aspect of
who you are to the surface and share
that with the world
another thing to understand and to
appreciate is that it's never too late
when I was 31 years old I was drunk and
in rehab where I lived for a hundred
days I had no future at that point in
time I was completely alone in the world
by the time I was 40 I was not only
depressed I was despondent in the midst
of this existential crisis completely
confused about what I was gonna do with
my life it wasn't until I was about 43
or 44 years old where I really started
to connect with my interior life with my
spiritual life and began to express
myself more authentically this book
finding ultra that I wrote didn't come
out until I was 44 or 45 years old and I
started the podcast at that point and
now I'm 51 I'm an old man especially if
you're watching this on YouTube you're
probably 20-30 years younger than me so
it is never too late I'm still deeply in
love with doing the podcast and my
promise to you over the next thirty
million downloads is to continue to hone
my craft to become a better interviewer
to find the absolute best guest that I
can and deliver to you the finest most
helpful most insightful content to help
raise the bar on your own personal life
experience and I'll leave you with this
if you have that spark of inspiration if
you feel compelled or inspire to make
something to express yourself to create
understand one fundamental truth and it
is this the world needs more of who you
really are
and with that go out
and make something awesome oh and one
final note I almost forgot my friend
Gary Vee sent me four copies of his new
book crushing it if you have not read
this book please check it out it's great
it was number 2 on Amazon last week I'm
one of the case studies in the book I
think there's three or four pages about
my story in here I'm really grateful and
honored that he would include me in this
book I also am the voice of the
audiobook not the whole book but about
30% of it I read all the mail case
studies in the book the audio book comes
out this spring or summer I'm not sure
exactly when but in the meantime the
hard copy is available wherever you buy
books and I'm gonna give these four
copies away so to enter to win just
leave a comment below explaining why you
think you should be the proud recipient
of crushing it and I'll select those
four people in mail ml all right cool so
I hope you enjoyed this video it's been
a while like I said since I've kind of
spoken directly to camera if you'd like
to see me do more of this stuff let me
know below as well subscribe do all that
kind of stuff and I'll see you guys back
here soon peace
[Music]